my name I did die the Mustaine oh no
that was so boring oh no you got to do
that hey why did you do it
whoa I mean to do that
all right let's just get this over with
Oh for [ __ ] sake
yeah that's yeah box
box got nothing on me all right hurry
you gotta pick up the pace
yeah yeah we did this in the magic
maintenance T Lok at the entrance to
alpha labs for let's just say death is
coming
you don't know I guess it was right
death is coming son of a [ __ ] I didn't
save did I not easy enough to remember
but they still forgot I'm a [ __ ] step
and YH art can't get me better people
requesting full authority to hire and
fire my own all they share you got it
you're [ __ ] bad you'll burn
[Music]
I get down that barrel by get down up no
no get down that you [ __ ] barrel it's
impossible to see I mean ah that that's
good
quick save on that one you see that [ __ ]
box yes you see that [ __ ] box alright
time to kill them Begley gotta pick up
the pace
Oh Oh what are you looking at huh I
spanked you until you disappear and I
got the eye out for Kenya this time I'm
not gonna hate you all right so where's
the alpha lamb that's right give me all
of your [ __ ] give me the PDA open the
PDA it's George pooh-poohed poopa no
audio log I watched his email fire your
boss house it's kind of detention shows
first shift with this four times a month
you have to miss the chef getting tired
of your peg if you had prostate exam
knowledge month
god damn the judge and his excuses all
right here we go there's an elevator
battle protect me oh that's how I roll
oh that's how I roll Oh
am I wrong oh that's how I roll
all right take me down to the Paradise
City where the grass barrels are
disappeared and proceed with cargo
removal all right easy enough
what give me that [ __ ]
what am I supposed to do why did I click
a row if I can't click a route smoke
shells huh I knew you would do that
enough bad for me bad for me better
there shooting everyone shotgun is not
good from a distance there we go
anymore all right what what are you
doing that stop running
Oh double kill
okay Dwyer isn't good that was double
damn I'm good getting better this res
learning and [ __ ] all right now we can
go in here don't know if I should be
happy about that
ow footage spiders I hate them
stop shooting me that night oh come on
demon spawn you can never trust demons
bother anyone
that [ __ ] is great up spidered what
are you doing in here got at spiders
come on with the float [ __ ] off vodka
you got your friends huh you think
you're cold because you have many
friends what if there was like a million
beautifies you would meet so cool then
ha ha
all right we got an armored [ __ ] let's
see here I'm not cheating right now
gotta think Allah Oh number 48 hmm what
could it be ice it's run through three
four all of them yeah haha stupid ass
house Kendra ah what the hell shoot you
top left then penis is about to be
messin oh come on
way too much action right now calm your
kid fine I'm ready I'm ready I'm ready
what do you got what did his friend guy
in here are you in here
art is a house back I'll take that why
the hell would you political huh doesn't
work doesn't work you think maybe
underneath here not how's that what
isn't this who are you
I don't get it feel like we're missing
something
where it's so [ __ ] dark come on you I
know where was something not appearing
[ __ ]
no one likes a spider alright there we
go there we go
oh yeah what up one out
[ __ ] fatties more did I ever do to
fight it man what do you want
bloody spider but don't jump to spider
I'll have the last [ __ ] shot here I'm
going down spider
you better not follow me [ __ ]
what what oh I'm shooting barrel didn't
kill you that's okay
I shot the barrel that's all I need oh
you want to spawn well welcome to my
hell this is your house [ __ ] Mariana oh
you're my [ __ ] industry ambient what
you think a call do you think your call
ah I want you at you before you never
ride you should pathetic little demon
haha pathetic demon can't even spot em
too badass Oh anyone else what a tango
oh alright I don't want to talk with you
though I take that back wait so - odd
noise bad it's bad sir
each grenades junk food you love it oh
oh son of up take them I did your friend
go I did your friend go oh wow
stop stop stop stop you don't bite your
owner you don't do it what ya own
teleport
son of a barrel take the grenade it's
really tasty
that was a bad decision right there all
right think we got a health bank at
least we got that
oh no I smarter than men a fantastic
chef Emma Emma it's not when
what no running out of ammo come on Nate
nenene
take it
oh how about it
whoa okay one two three
works every time [ __ ] why do i this
one open may I thank you
and I'm alpha labs tres doing pretty
good pretty good not bad at least pretty
good Rab that's a new expression just
invented in that's for you Syrian you
mean the loading screen again
alright let's just keep going week yeah
able to locate your position okay can't
hear ya thank God
Raul team adjust into the input all
right Warren for pick up the pages what
they [ __ ] telling me the entire
[ __ ] game that's what I'm doing
hey hi there know all your traps and you
have to okay fine
huh no cats on gotta look at it up no no
that is terrible
what hi buddy how it hurts when you
shoot me
you don't only hurt my feelings that's
why I threw need yeah jeez do you want
to come at me
I left a need for you out [ __ ] came back
let's go down to funky town let's go out
and party all night long
one two three what I ah doesn't work hey
[ __ ] I didn't do that
alright we're good to go
no stuffed up on a bed second three
alright turn a turn eight
negative ads drag back and then gosh
shut spider spider spider spider I shoot
you not gosh oh they're up there
you can draw with me good back to pass
spider too fast you're fat hey hiya ha
ha what are you doing it
down river that's how I roll that's how
I get oh you want fo diem it doesn't
even English what the hell did I just
say there don't know you're dead you're
all dead
I got a pistol see I'm on here Karen see
how much I care see how much I care this
is how much I can - no Mike oh yeah I'm
sorry I'm taking back what are you doing
you're nuts oh my [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] mother [ __ ] bow down
day down nice roll
you're not supposed to be here anyone
else want a tango I have flashlight as
he doing sting me
that's how I roll that's how I get the
ladies no no [ __ ] count dad how did
you survive that should not be possible
don't force a bleep or situation what
all right hurry with what doing much
spiders are talking to me now shut up
spider get on top
stop wasting ammo booty well I read of
the game this message is on your area hi
Percy the VFR day way activating the
sewage we're about as an exchange about
it let's go there now strange four
little legs
you just chilling in there or what
ginger up your conversation I didn't
mean to oh stop stop what stop I'm
asking time man they just don't suck oh
wow I'm out of here throw out of here I
don't like you [ __ ] but I wanted yo
doing [ __ ] [ __ ] everywhere alright
close up
stop you're pissing me off man you too
not the bat all right yeah buddy
stop him stop stop stop stop stop stop
stop
get him out pest you fish Amir everyone
is pissing everyone is pitching everyone
is pissing everyone is picking yes again
that's a good a good is mojang man what
the hell are you anyway if I say stop it
they stop what fight oh okay let's not
rush that much I was stupid
it's really step in my life turns
episode a elephant with a dying I don't
know why but like very much enjoyed just
got a coverage today and I'll see you
next episode
oh boy Abba I'm a Salesman maja sure mo
activate ah no no no no no no no no no
all right